but I wasn't jerking off like I went to
my little period how long I took a
couple of weeks and I'm on two months
right now I use it's August 3rd you're
all about self-discipline yeah I was
like yeah like you're like let me let me
slip yeah let me make like nothing any
touches he's gonna do
oh yeah work of a hard-on that's a stuff
that's obsessive oh yeah yeah yes those
showers I gotta clean yourself do you
like your dick is more sensitive now
yeah man and it makes me it also makes
me more social I'm able to [ __ ] chubbier
to girls I'm just like I gotta get all
right you're not selling this well how
the [ __ ] fatter girl I mean ah buddy up
instead of her like I feel like going
out now like yeah yeah yeah like after
shows like one come for drinks you know
if it's like just then I would always go
but in like three of their friends like
just give me your number but now I'm
like yeah let's go up we need to yeah
you get me cuz I don't have any other
option right now it's mobile blowing
have you had nocturnal emissions no but
I wet my bed still so I wouldn't know
you wet your bed no I'm joking
I did 16 so I did I don't know if I had
what yours when I was little you want
you better you're 16 you know it was it
was bad why'd you do that it's not like
I [ __ ] stood over it is my bed was
there any was there any medical
explanation no I don't know man it just
I just do it I couldn't stop it pray to
God to help me he didn't listen to
eliminate yes ervil's not gonna stop
infanticide or clitoral circumcisions
your bed was not at the top listen that
is like a lot I got a cure already real
quick yeah so why'd you why'd you stop
jerking off I was about I was in Dublin
I was about to go to Edinboro for a
month I was going to live with four
dudes
DeRosa and these three three whatever
items like I want to jerk off at three
and also I was like I wanted to make me
like try to [ __ ] a chicken it to some
paleface Scottish chick uh-huh and so it
did I hope they were like a few of them
and why would you you wanted to make it
because then you like we said you have
to right yeah oh yeah exactly it just it
just makes you do it yeah so yeah some
girls like it scalps it kiss absolutely
let's go hang out um yeah do you ever
have the problem of like drive to like
go get laid yes yeah god I'm the worst
yeah jerk it off in the phones
it really does that's their nature but
you also love like
the hooker thing not as much anymore not
really no really no no cuz it's gonna
say obviously you know if like that's
part of it right is paying a girl so
you're not gonna go out and meet
somebody you know III jerked off last
night I couldn't sleep I was on the like
it was 1:00 in the morning and I got and
I'm like Joe's helplessly dumped a load
and I put a little paper towel by the
bed and I was [ __ ] it was such a dish
that you could gobble onto the paper
towel no it was such a good load I was
jerking off I just had my dick head
rubbing into my stomach when I came it
was literally like somebody was like it
was asleep just vomiting on my stomach
it was the worst grossest [ __ ]
village man come a big thick one - all
over your belly oh my god it was [ __ ]
awful it was like there was like a
little I was like if someone was just
throwing cottage cheese on it and I
dollop tit off paper towel barely got
all of it and I [ __ ] dozed off while
it hardened on my my [ __ ] uh my
buddy's gross you can peel it off like
no no harden on the towel no but my
mouth guard that's a fun mistake yeah
did I jerked off once in Israel I was
thinking about my aunt and uncle's house
I jerked off into it into a tissue and I
put it by the bed went to sleep and then
when I woke up it was just his trail of
ants from the window and just all over
that tissue oh I loved it they felt
there's a very sweet jizz oh I must have
heard right it's changed now that I'm
not a virgin anymore but yeah then when
I hooked up last night with like a
good-looking girl and it was like I just
got so much harder and like eat eat
right yeah and then the middle of night
like an hour later my chills now again
instead of like I'm good for a week she
way in the wind you later this one yeah
I met her I hooked up with like a year
ago you still use social like the dating
apps on one certainty find me a date
there's no dating yeah no no I stopped
with tinder I never told you about 10m
like you gotta get on that man I need
some nice people on those apps like I
like shares who like them especially for
just a nice person I am yeah I joined
out let's say there's no lie I keep a
couple of bumbles old hat to me this one
here where's this phone now but I
haven't met anyone yet which work
there's there's this one I went on
transcribe
yeah and then that one another one like
Trans Am I met no one what uh what's
your percentage of women to uh other you
know it's gray clay is it is a really
good trip believe me I've asked myself
that uh I guess it all depends I go
through phases have you done an
accounting like sure you'll go through
phases where you're just hooking up with
trans people hope you're not just
hooking up now I never am just hooking
up no you ever had a girlfriend this
trans uh uh would you sure we're gonna
have my girlfriend so do you it's been a
while right
no it's been since I had a real
girlfriend like I can in Lyle of you I
love you too was 2011 I've dated since
then I've had a couple of girls I've
dated who I liked very much but it was
more casual so when you're going through
one of your phases though what's the
ratio of trans to non trans like what
percentage it honestly could change from
day to day
this never come across too right I'm
sure yeah it really is like that there's
never like okay only that you know to me
I'm never going to not love a big fat
vagina like wherever I can't and I'm not
saying that just to tell myself it you
know this distant that will never not
turn me on right but you got love for a
dick connected to some tits to I'm
working with one so it's a tough it's a
tough racket but it's just not there
they need to put that at that [ __ ]
that option on tinder what trans option
I think oh yeah sensibility they have
male and female and they have Grindr if
you I don't want to go on Grindr I'm not
looking to me men he's got it he's the
update they could do it because then you
got to go on the trans app it's a lot a
lot of them are just escorts and stuff
it's not you're not looking for that no
there's so many those apps now it's kind
of crazy dating apps dating out there
herpes for herpes people really yeah
they have all sorts of stuff that's
right you were do you blow your load
quicker now because you don't jerk off
sometimes yeah yeah yeah you gotta like
be careful yeah but then it's like this
you know ii i've been do a little longer
but like uh yeah sometimes got to be
like I just feel like going down you
again you just did like yeah you know we
should do it again now had 20 seconds of
sex is enough for a little bit
doesn't make you more sensitive is you
know that late with the thoughts we'll
turn you on yeah off turn you want just
like the ideas are gone what God look at
that so your every thought again I feel
like I also slow down weed so now like
when I get high get high so you dick guy
was desensitized a little bit right from
jerking off slightly yeah for sure and
you're really watching porn not as well
for what exactly what the storyline the
rapid videography yeah there's no crease
across for me so what do you like you
just go through some pictures now
instead of like cool I got a picture
from you now it's like oh yeah cuz
that's what you have yeah look at those
hooters or whatever you say I'm not even
tired each our school yeah look at all
this